[Musique]
votre vue baisse de jour en jour
quel genre d'homme tu es
vraiment malade
parce qu'on est
fermé les yeux
vous pouvez être n'importe où
[Musique]
comment vous êtes arrivés ici peut-être
que je suis venu pour vous aider
c'est compliqué les relations j'aime ma
femme
[Musique]
calme-toi bonsoir
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas avec votre tête
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive je comprends pas
je vois des choses qu'est-ce que tu vois
exactement il voit des sons et peuvent
goûter les couleurs ils peuvent même
entendre des odeurs
[Musique]
ça est bien et à la fin
comment vous vous appelez je suis
personne
[Musique]
qui s'était
un autre faux
[Musique]